herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
ich bin nicht alleine sondern zusammen
mit luca haben servers überlegt ihr seht
schon den titel dieses youtube diensten
youtuber werden auf die idee gekommen
und zwar ist es wirklich so lustig wie
simpel wir haben beide vier dumme
challenges und überlegt wir haben beide
jeweils vier dumme aufgaben auf diese
technik hingeschrieben beispiel ein paar
schere stein papier darum wer eine
aufgabe ziehen nur eine sache die ich
aufgeschrieben habe das ganze video
gezeigt es gibt einfach nicht mehr zu
reden wir fangen an schere stein papier
schere stein papier als erste den ich in
meine damen und herren ermittelt ganze
noch ein bisschen durch ob ich jetzt
kämpfen wir etwa dem anderen drei
komplimente machen käfer dann gemeint
was mach ich dir für komplimente kommt
nummer eins ich bewundere seinen
durchhaltevermögen das konsequente
youtube uploads und generell arbeiten wo
am stück angeht weil ich selbst das bei
mir ein bisschen vermisse nur zwei weil
ich auch auf youtube ist im schnitt die
schnellste schneiden kann dank des 23
[Musik]
das guten mordkomplotts
für die 1 die komplimente die wenig
eingefallen auf meine youtube sache
bezogen waren studenten gute bittet
kompliment wer weiß szene junge tier war
auch was hast du dir endlich ich hätte
bei uns gesagt du du kauft und auf dich
gerne und auch eigentlich ganz gut
eigentlich ganz gut aber kein verein
weitergeht
wäre es beim papier sowie einbiegen um
man eltern packen wir auf ich habe da
das wort von du kannst etwas bei mir
höre not afraid mit kopfhörern und singe
laut mitteilungen weg aber wir hören das
was marx wegen das heißt würde sagen los
geht muss auch mit rapperin und den
refrain
du musst nur den refrain das davor nein
keine lektüre herrlich auf mittlere
betriebe die eine liegt nur hören könnt
[Musik]
ja ich verstehe aber ich kann in den
text wird die löwen und ich hoffe ich
habe dich für diesen titel entschieden
deutschland verliere dann von dir von
der letzten sache erzählen bei der duh
versagt hat so richtig versagt wird
peinlich es friedlich unangenehm dass
leute das erfahren er denkt ist
wahrscheinlich so luca überlegt weil er
keine sachen heißt berliner versagt
dazu hat das keiner führt
walter ich habe wirklich keine ahnung
wenn ich jetzt sagen würde irgendwas
ganz krassen wo ich vermag dann bin ich
glaube ich jetzt sagen ist dass ich eine
klausur echt mit 50 leider nicht
bestanden habe und die musik die tagen
wiederholen also das ist schon eine
krasse sache nie versagt hat aber jetzt
wirklich dass es jetzt auch schon zwei
routen ob das in ordnung dann ändert
sich und geöffneter verloren
die 5 also die nächste sich nehmen muss
ist dieses kleine zettelchen himmel
wieder informiert
das bietet mir ja nein sagen das hab ich
auch geschrieben und ich dachte
eigentlich dass du das nimmt gerne ganz
am anfang und dann keine ahnung ob und
wenn ja wie man ohne bestrafung steht er
nicht
sie könnten einfach nicht fehlen wie
auch die die beiden wörter sagen hat
ihnen hat er zu wenig hätte gerade stein
und luca 4
ich hoffe es ist das ist nein ich hab
mich auch dass in die vierer ohne kappe
zu machen zehn sekunden lang ein
liebling ist das neue markt- oder wieder
aufnehmen
ich glaube mir der fall so willst du
machen sollst du sahel oder etwas was
kein normalsterblicher singen kann
mir macht das jeder sehen kann der vater
hat das rote pferd immer umgekehrt
[Musik]
mit knapper sorte per sich einfach
umgekehrt und hat mit seinem schwanz
tiefflieger abgewehrt ich liege war
nicht um wie machte gründung und wird
mit ihrem buch vor der fährte um
genannten vergab für ein tempo vor
mit älteren kann ich doch jetzt wird
wieder stehen sie können wir direkt
zurück jetzt da ich hoffe dass das was
ich auch glücklich aber für die bürger
erwähnt das nein das ist wieder von dir
zehn sekunden bekannt ich weiß nicht was
angeht weil ich habe getroffen
aufgeschrieben warum habe ich immer zehn
sekunden lang zehn sekunden laufen
[Musik]
ende
wir leben hier haben wir schon 1 2 3 4 5
6 4 noch zwei da drin ist das eine was
ich nicht die kraft wird über wenige
chancen drankommt als 40 top mannschaft
nicht reingeredet börsen durch mitnimmt
du verrät man kann nicht telefonieren
mit einer flasche und tue so als würde
deine mutter liegt für uns recht für
etwas beschäftigt die bildqualität und
das wird ne flasche bringt hallo ja ich
hab gemacht haben
nein ich habe das nicht gemacht ich
schwöre ich war das nicht der fall
bastian gm aber freiheit war nicht nur
die flasche rainha nehmen
mama ich war das nicht ich hab den hund
mit auf den boden gelegt
meine mutter in der aufnahme und jetzt
kommt's zum letzten meine damen und
herren komplettanschlüsse verfügung
ich fühle mich entscheidend ist zwar
schon sehr darauf in ihrer jugend bleibt
kaputt gemacht dafür müssen zwei sachen
nehmen die hexen okay jetzt aufgabe
mache so viele liegestütze wieder
schafft ohne pause
doch je kuh stellt sich dann mein verein
ich weiß nicht wer mein persönliches
ziel den 20 ohne pause
21 25 20 30 war schon der weg noch heute
wenn ich das getan hat dass man etwas
nochmal sehen wollt dass vielleicht das
abschalten lassen leisten bist du nie
wieder